according to a recent survey 85% of
women on social media say they've
witnessed moms shaming other moms a new
startup is trying to create a safe space
online for working mothers Chairman mom
is a subscription-based website that
charges users 5 dollars a month its goal
is to cut down abuse trolling and
mumbling it's the brainchild of Sarah
Lacy a working mom in San Francisco who
founded tech website Pando and spent
years reporting on the tech industry
good morning good morning thank you for
having me so do you think that that
social media has failed working moms yes
and I think it's largely because women
and people of color were not in the room
when these platforms were created people
always ask me you're pushing so hard for
diversity in Silicon Valley how would
things look different and I think we
wouldn't see the abuse that we see on
social media if it were different we
have now seen a 10-15 year arc of this
great promise of giving people these
tools for free and all we're gonna do is
show you some ads what we've seen how
that experiment worked
we got addicted we got emotionally
manipulated and particularly women were
exposed and abused we we have helped
made billions of dollars for
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley as the
biggest users of these platforms and
we're the most abused and Tara and mom
is about ending that abusive relation of
used how that's mom shaming mom bullying
mommy war what what I wanted an example
of mom bullying what and so you know oh
you're saying that you know stay-at-home
moms are better you're saying working
moms are better I mean this division
that comes up in our country I mean 40
percent of Americans think it's bad for
society if moms work that is a deep
entrenched bias that makes working moms
feel guilty for following their dreams
and doing something great for their
families and by the same token stay at
mom Jose said home moms shouldn't feel
guilty why do I care what you're doing
with your kids I focused on my life and
my kid you talkin baited into this you
talk about a Silicon Valley billionaire
I would like to know who that is least
initials but he made you a bet that made
that made you think about rebranding
moms what was the bet it said this do
you want to say who it is I don't wanna
say it's because it's actually someone
who is super supportive and a large
investor in Mike
after the facts oh he learned but when I
was pregnant with my first child
Eli I was massively pregnant I was like
a 200-pound pregnant woman and I was
planning a conference in China and I was
gonna be on stage for four days and I
had spent two years planning this
conference in China so I did not know
I'd be pregnant in the middle of it you
know the date of the conference was six
weeks after my due date and now like a
first-time mom I've been told by society
I would be a mess after becoming
pregnant and this billionaire told me
there's no way you're gonna leave and
get on that plane after holding your
baby in your arms to the point where you
made a hundred dollar bet with me and I
was like you're saying I'm gonna throw
away everything I've worked before when
I suddenly have a baby but that's what
we tell women about mother and you were
willing how do women in the marketplace
act oh because you have you have the
confessional mommy blogger who talks
about how impossible it is and they
attract a certain group of people who
say yes finally somebody's talking about
my reality but then the market it seemed
to shift to pictures of family that are
perfect where everybody looks great in
the pictures and that gets the audience
but it also is a kind of shaming some
people feel because they're like I can
never live that life so how is that
transition in audience and again part of
what you're describing is everyone being
in these ad based systems what gets you
the most clicks as of it as an
influencer as a mom influencer having
this perfect family well that just makes
other women somehow feel lesser than
even though we know everyone's family is
crazy and chaotic for me I just felt
like I had been cold my whole adult life
becoming a mother would be this insane
disability that would change who I was
and I felt like it was a superpower I
felt like I could suddenly shoot like
webs out of my palms like I became more
productive I became a better manager I
never would have had the courage or
confidence to start my own company
without having my children well Sharon
Chairman mom yeah we are rooting for you
thank you like it a lot thank you Sarah
Lacey